it's me right that's right next up is oh
my favorite best complaining about
america award oh we have plenty of these
god knows like how do we know where do
we where how do we narrow it down how do
we begin yeah uh let's have a look at
the nominations then boys shall we yeah
all right so the first one is explaining
why budweiser is back if there is an
instant karma compilation this would
also be on it all right
the thing is i never tried a budweiser
up until now because all i've heard is
that it tastes like [ __ ]
so that's why i never tried it but now i
kind of like it
sizes in japan versus sizes in the us
i'm thinking that's talking about coffee
sizes and food sizes oh all right i see
um actually i don't need to watch that
clip right yeah yeah that's fine i mean
i don't think we need to watch all these
clips because they're going to be very
long clips
there's a lot of so we can explain them
because i remember most of these
uh there's very few things i do remember
on trash days but complaining about
america is definitely one of them
um so yeah explaining why budweiser is
bad um i'm not sure if that was like a
complaining about america moment as much
as it was otherwise it is america yeah
it's amazing it's it's the mountains
as much as you can as much as you're
just complaining about american beer
period yeah and then we uh we definitely
shot ourselves in the foot uh and then
in the in our own faces afterwards um
sizes in japan versus sizes in the usa
coffee and stuff like that yeah
everything yeah everything in america
have just been true everything is just
everything is just too big also yeah
america's stupid way of writing dates
okay it is come on you got it i mean
this isn't even a trash taste com
complaining yeah it's it's it's just
like this is the wall complaining yeah
yeah and of course the chef chef mac
insults new york on the cooking special
in like record
because it was just such a
unplanned moment yeah where we just had
like we were just trying to be wholesome
you know we're trying to be comforting
we had to like we had a guest on just
hadn't wanted to have a nice
conversation immediately complains about
america like it wasn't even scripted no
no no no no
i was just gonna ask like oh so how did
you get your position or what's your
experience and you just like yeah so uh
yeah
and then one time we had meline on and
we needed some backup so we asked
melanie what she thinks about us talking
[ __ ] about america yeah which uh was us
complaining about us complaining about
america yeah and then of course we had
the americans that microwaved their
water yeah i will never forgive that
yeah
that's unforgivable yeah that is a war
crime that is geneva convention defying
right and it's it's funny because the
only one the one of the biggest ones
aside from this one
one of the biggest ones i've seen in
america is still defend is the microwave
their water
how could you defend that this is how
you know that you know that eclipse is
like i will never forgive the japanese
that's why you'll never forgive the
americans
i just don't get it it just doesn't make
sense yeah
um for this one though i do hope the
chef mac one wins just i want the
american microwave on the room either of
those could honestly win but it's it's
between those two just i love the chef
mac one just for how unplanned it was
and just like the like the fastest how
fast it was the fastest bonding
experience to be like oh you're one of
us okay okay you'll get a yo you'll fit
right in you'll feel right there
definitely all right yeah well the
winner is gentlemen yes let us know if
you're not it's
americans microwaving their walls oh
well
you know what i i feel like i feel like
the rest of the world united in yeah in
like yeah voting for that w plus i asked
plus i cared yeah exactly right
what was the percentage that at one bar
uh that one won with 37.3 percent of the
votes
second was you guys explaining why
budweiser is bad with 18.8 percent of
the vote yeah fair fair and americans
writing their dates wrong came in third
without 14.5 percent of the vote so i
think it was just so good at predicting
this yeah i think it's just like the
world uniting about what they can like
it's everything every every person but
americans and like
coming together to be like what do we
actually agree on what's the common
complaint yeah what's the most common
complaint
all right joey what's the next category
the next one oh this one's going to be a
hot contender
best meme oh
we had a lot of great memes that the
subreddit and the twitter have created
fantastic matches
honestly
any of these could win but uh let's see
what the nominations are all right so
for starters we have the dark timeline
yes which i'm a little like behind on
because i think this kind of came onto
the subreddit when i deleted reddit off
my phone yeah this is this has come
pretty recently yeah um and we haven't
talked about it i guess yeah but it's
still pretty timely because it would
have been two weeks i guess since the
dark timeline started um what the [ __ ]
yeah i like
all i know is that it makes fate look
normal yeah i'm kind of waiting for it
to finish yeah let's let's go through
that's all let's go through all the
categories first before and god said
of course yes of course uh i'm nasty
christmas
and then evil trash trash taste so like
i think the biggest difference between
this year's memes and last year's memes
is that
like our reddit has a hive mind of its
own now there are two memes here that we
did not create or we had a zero hand in
okay iron mouse is chris yeah how did
that
start i don't know it was like it was
like two characters that seemingly had
nothing to do with one another yeah yeah
yeah yeah trash taste lore and then
someone was like what if they're the
same person yeah yeah yeah which i which
is great
there was like such good fan art out of
it and everything like that like the i
think one of my favorites is the one
where like uh iron mouse is piloting a
mech of chris yeah yeah
i think my favorite thing about the iron
mouse is chris meme is that none of us
are in it
like it literally has nothing to do with
the trash taste and yet it's a trash
taste me it just shows that the trash
taste law has gone has expanded so much
that it's like gone we don't trust yeah
it doesn't even need us anymore it's
good though because then chris went on
iron mountain's talk show as well
and then the timeline which i believe is
still ongoing yeah right to this day i
think i i i would bet my entire net
worth that the timeline is gonna wins
because of the recency
and the subreddit loves it they all love
it well like
it's not just like the recency because
recency bias is also
like it's it's take like i am
[ __ ]
impressed by the amount of effort that
has gone into this what this is not a
meme anymore this has gone beyond a meme
it's it is
like they're literally pulling they're
literally pulling like a tagashi and
like [ __ ] like graphing everything
out and they're like okay so this
happens while this was happening and
then this happens next yeah it's just
like fake fans and kingdom heart fans
think no one can like defeat them until
like they look like a dark timeline i'm
like okay i bow to my lord like i i
looked at like the time and i'm like
[ __ ] you now how would you make sense of
this like this youtube explainer videos
on the dark timeline are you serious
yeah there's a few oh my god and like
and some of them don't even explain it
very well yeah like i don't really get
it but
yeah and like the thing that blows my
mind the most
is that we have had zero involvement
into it we we did not create it we did
not even say something that like could
like fuel it that fueled it you know
what i mean it it it is like our
subreddit completely like just having a
maha like a mind of its own
like it's it's
our subreddit is self-sustaining at this
point honestly these two memes prove it
yeah definitely all right well uh let's
find out then yeah who got the best how
much did the dark timeline wouldn't buy
yeah let's find out i guess uh so the
winner for the best meme of the year
goes to
the dark timeline yeah not even
not even surprised congrats sir congrats
congratulations reddit uh your fan
fiction made it
oh my god it's a bad feather it's
i'm not doing it it's literally a fan
fiction i'm not even joking why are you
going to do them like that joey why are
you going to do like this this is so
much more than that jerry it's a
cohesive universe
i didn't sacrifice the past he thought
waiting for you to call it a [ __ ]
fanfiction joey i didn't die in an
earthquake for you to call it a
fanfiction
if you don't know what i sacrificed joey
it doesn't even make sense yeah i'm
looking at this and i'm like first of
all what the [ __ ] is that face on the
left there oh
who actually
made this [ __ ] image i know how
difficult and how time-consuming it is
to make an image like this
um it is this is sponsored by the bbc
like
this is the initial oh it's the local
timeline yeah this is like i mean this
is like a really high effort meme you
know this is all yeah yeah this is
extremely high effort
keep it coming
honestly i want to see how it concludes
what percentage did it win by is the
real question well the dark timeline
came in first with thirty five point one
percent of that oh wow that's not as
much as i thought it was gonna be yeah
second place is iron mouse's chris with
twenty three point seven percent of
course of course that have nothing to do
with us audrey the dark times
this is like the reddit like giving
themselves the medal to be like guys we
did a great job
i'll be like we didn't read it we did it
congratulations reddit